if it feels good do it if I lost my
scalpel screw it hokey pokey pokey pokey
pokey pokey pokey pokey there we go oh
you're gonna work II don't feel so happy
yo hey guys and welcome back to surgeon
simulator you know the drill so I don't
need to explain it now if only I could
find the drill I would be able to get
started on this son [ __ ] no get back on
there it's a button and do nothing else
until I tell you to you are a complete
inanimate object unlike many of the
things oh good my hammer this will be
very useful Boosh bass [ __ ] boss burst
burst British boys Oh how's it going
Bobby seemed to have some loose teeth up
and oh we're nope I don't got it that's
not where I suppose it no stop going up
ah so I'm going up hit the hit the teeth
and only the teeth teeth and only teeth
please teeth and only teeth why in the
world what the instructions say that the
drill is good for removing teeth it is
obviously the worst the pammer is the
best Bob as you could stop complaining
for two seconds I would be able to get
don't close your mouth on me young man
that's right open it frequently wide for
the drill Oh
oh well how's that jugular doing for you
has it healed up since the last time
that I stabbed into it oh come on
got it finally you dick you douche Oh
little baby's getting his teeth removed
why didn't you just go crying back to
his mama and stop bleeding for two
seconds so I can get my job done
no hammer no drill I can't work under
these conditions at all doctor you could
hammer and drill me all day long Bob Oh
nurse what did you turn into Mickey no
that's his upper lip this is not what I
wanted the drill is not the right tool
for this the drill is absolutely baloney
they can't possibly want me to use the
drill for this
this is absolutely ridiculous there is
no way that this is supposed to work on
lockdown I'm in it to win it because I'm
winning it right now oh did I get it
oh I almost got it yeah what Bob does
this hurt just yell at me if it hurts
okay got the top ones out I just need to
get them off oh oh oh don't tie me now
Bob there are some glues oh no no no no
no no no get in there okay that's a good
front molar that's a good side front
molar you're all open up for you doc
well our Stoll cooperate God dingus damn
it you do something you do something oh
no I couldn't let it go before now I
can't pick it up oh come on I'm so close
to winning and you won't get in there
you did it get in there from blood loss
face I don't need a buzz saw for your
face just yet Oh No
oh boy these know I wanted a happy pill
there's a hammer and they'll give me yah
fast fast big ham our big ham our time
for face doesn't even fit in face oh
yeah oh yeah oh that's Claire got it put
it back put it back good points yeah
charge it up do its dance Oh your teeth
you still in there maybe the big hammer
was not the best idea
come on come on come on come on got it
did I get it I didn't get them all get
it go get it what's way back in there
what's up deuce thing is that all about
I put teeth in you oh good good good
good
love it love it love it love it my
favorite my favorite my favorite did
when they don't decide to go in okay you
didn't need to have that all the way in
there wait you're gonna die unless I can
stop your bleeding somehow but
unfortunately no one wants to give me a
green goo be Gabby Ducey donkey oh well
that's one hell of a blade but that's
not what I read no give me that
no no don't be good and shut up Bob I
don't have time for you deuce is this
whose justice
this is this I don't want the drill that
drill don't work maybe I just wasn't
using the drill delicately enough and
then no that's blood I see blood bloods
bad oh you're right on it you're not
right oh no that was the face okay I
think I got the all the bottom I think
it wait I feel a little bit more there
get that Oh gone it's gone gone good
good good now I'm gonna put this down
for just a second it's gonna drill into
your neck with that
datura it's gonna tuck it in there like
a little baby
like a little baby computer how thing
it's very creepy and I'm gonna stop your
bleeding by doing this a lot into your
side of your face gonna feel real good
cuz it's like some pink I'm gonna just
have that injecting constantly into your
neck you're gonna be totally fine
I can't angle that camera down well it's
a dyad there we go oh no no no no no no
oh no no no no you come back here Bob
Yuuka beggar I know you don't want it
but you gotta have it I'm getting
everything I want
oh I need the cure
I need the cure just get that little bit
it's so tiny I see it in there oh I see
it get bash did I get it how the hell is
it still in there
get out
I think I got it oh my god I think I got
it oh god oh god oh god Hogarth
oh gosh oh gosh no no he's gonna bleed
to death on four give me a syringe no
okay now we can't possibly bathe bleed
anymore but what I need is the cure for
my own idiocy yeah oh I'm gonna give it
the OL one-two though you blew your skip
to you Lou and then hoop-dee-doo yes yes
yes oh yeah oh oh finally always heart
rates a little high let's make sure that
doesn't happen let's take a little
breather Bob isn't that nice isn't that
nice the way that is not being a douche
it's good huh
feels good for your soul feels real good
for your soul oh oh my god Wow
whoo I've like literally layers and
layers of sweat on my face god nothing
gets me more into it than this game it
is most it is one of my most hated and
my most beloved games of all time ah
okay I think there was a very last new
thing for surgeon simulator if it isn't
let me know but otherwise thank you guys
so much for watching hope you enjoyed
these videos if you did please take a
second to click the like button down
below
it'll mean a lot to me and if you want
to see more I've got a huge playlist of
surgeon simulator stuff check out the
annotation or a link in the description
thank you again for watching and as
always I will see you